beh io sono felice oggi siamo su lucky
tower che questo gioco dalle anteprime e
bellissimo poi non lo so mi chiese con
quei tuoi capelli sono veramente belli
zio che veramente donald trump secondo
me adesso ti copia lei allora ragazzi
siamo su un raise mila te un race che in
questo è vabbè però move jump duck cosa
vuol dire poi ucciderti per premendo
campa va bene aggiungiamo qualche altro
tasso già che ci siamo
[Musica]
oltre quasi cagarmi addosso e comunque
era la colonna sonora di quad entrava la
mia prof di fisica in classe questo è
successo
cos'è sta roba lì è un castello è una
torre della chitarra e ovviamente ci
sono ci mette un po ad arrivare però io
quindi devo scappare che figata sono in
cima alla torre ok sicuramente farei
male a tutti quanti con queste mosse in
schiva abili zio va bene ragazzi allora
andiamo a scappare lo stato cosa c'è
dietro
proviamo a far vedere cosa ci dite la
porta con la col sangue ok prima vedere
una chiusa
cosa che c'è ma io quindi non devo
entrare nella porta giusta che non è
questa madama che figata è merda salve
credo sia la porta giusta neanche questo
tre game o ragazzi buona su tre giusta
ovviamento dovuto provarle tutte per
azzeccarla perché sono cazzo dall'altro
c'è anche già anche la faccina felice
per indicarti che la porta è giusta ma
[ __ ] che ne sapevo vabbè andiamo
avanti
quindi abbiamo la partenza è stata la
merda ma tanto di tutti i giochi così
allora zio o metti i sottotitoli in
inglese ramente me la cavo come matteo
renzi
sì però una e mezza aperta in quella lì
mi sa che non entrò tra l'altro adesso
ci faccio caso i singoli sulle porte qua
c'è un cuore chiama dice il cuore era
giusta questa volevi fottermi bastardo
in queste non c'è niente caso qualcuno
che ha voglia di chiesto
perché io non vedo i trabocchetti
[ __ ] eva perché ci finisco dentro non
posso fare passettini qual è la portai
ho scelto adesso non me lo ricordo più
assolutamente non era questa non era
questa perché l'altra dalla destra
quindi perfetto ok ok era quella giusta
perfetto ma io non ho capito ma devo
andare a culo c'è veramente scritto
qualcosa sulle porte che non vedo sempre
tipo adesso non lo sto vedendo sembrano
tutte uguali ste porte me on line mezzo
[Musica]
aveva avevate per caso anche solo mezzo
dubbio allora conti il grosso stato
maledetto promotions cerberus
no no no la porta è sbagliata
poi ho fatto bene il suo peso ma si è
fatto così bene questa ok
beh a posto basta ridere che stai
morendo tutte le volte che canzone
perché sai vedevo demoman arti posso
comprare delle cose ma tema veramente
voglio comprare questo cappello
bellissimo grazie nelle armi voglio
questo dopo il martello il fratello
grazie sei stato molto gentile
me ne vado ma che bello e ora che
fashion questo cappello sei bellissimo
zio stavolta c'è la faccina entrò in
quella della facile la zia faccio io
frate con martello
quella non è la porta giusta praga
[ __ ] è possibile madama veramente
ce la fai a fare una cosa giusta e
questa è l'ultima mi chiama sempre
l'ultima la porta quella che devo
azzeccare o pian piano sto scendendo
buongiorno doveva questo cosa fa
vorresti che io entrassi qua dentro sé
ma è invece no proviamo l'ultimo non
entra in quella dove entrata quel tizio
perché lo so che è sbagliata lo so ciao
zio è una madonna dovrai trovata sta
roba
ho preso la mazza che secondo me è un po
meglio non lo so e poi magari non è così
però si chiama lei ma tempo pure e va
bene così stronza l'ultima per forza
sicuro niente indovinate quale era
quella giusta ragazzi provate a
indovinare cazzo cazzo volete a chi sono
ma cos'è sta gente sotto zio 18 st vacca
è mai difficilissimo radio dai tg o
prova la vicina arti cross finotti
questo nostro famiglia perfetto già
facciamo ai ragazzi prima o poi ci sarà
una base in questa torre maledetta
quanto è lunga già frate cazzo ma cosa
vuole maestro muten sexy man sexy ma non
troppo però vabbè mi sta seguendo che
bello che quando corre non ho capito
mandiamo prima lui e sulla prima
[Musica]
era quella giusta ma se è andato e non è
tornato dovrebbe essere quello più se è
andato non è tornato potrebbe essere
anche morto infatti è morto vabbè ce
l'ha chiesto tizio col rosso go2 vai con
la porta numero 2 maestro muten infatti
crescere i capelli
no no va bene questa perfetto ok sono
contenti si salva l'amiu staff in star a
si beve bello questo lo voglio
va bene con le presine picchio ho capito
di qua la prima salta subito no stavolta
mi sa che sbagliato alcuni talk quindi
non basta
ok dai gal che fa peso come faccio
porca vacca ok a dio santo ho fatto ho
fatto perfetto michele quant'è difficile
suo gioco la prima me lo sento che la
prima però c'è anche una volta giusto
buttare una volta che azzecco il primo
tentativo porta era non esiste già ho
sbagliato a cliccare il tasto è quanta
gente
ok più forte le altre come è possibile
mia marte dove si spaccargli la faccia
di brutto ma che problemi hai frate
abbassati abbassati e cammina non può
camminare se ha passato ed efficiente
vabbè non entrarci che devo dire
dall'altra parte che palle
ma serio
[Musica]
ho capito ma zio e zia veloce cazzo
funziona benissimo a posto no ovviamente
l'aspetto sicuro giusto sarebbe
idilliaco non ci voglio credere
l'ultimo a regolo giusto privare i pesci
che problemi ma cos'è sta roba una
foglia perché verde cia comitato sul
posto dai baffi home with rics wii
tricks bit trip chowdhry xché bello chi
sei
picchiare va bene non andiamo andiamo
andiamo sei troppo carino sei troppo
carino o siamo arrivati muore mai
scateni negate mia ti piace e mi spiace
non te lo posso dare però se tu mi dai
questo spiedino di dopo io sono
contentissimo grazie cos'è sta roba
harry potter vada tuo paese
allora niente questo se uscissimo mai ad
uscire da scompiglia non così però no
così facciamo tipo dico andate dici ok
perfetto agguantato la chiave ma posso
ciò seccato miglia per una volta
incredibile o siamo quasi arrivati al
pianterreno e ragazzi mi piacciono messo
una vita va bene capisco no no no no te
lo faccia re mio no è mio è mio forte
che no dai zio
però la mia faccia non lo possono anche
uccidere bastardo mi ero affezionato
quel palla di pelo rossa cose che c'è
qua dentro
[Musica]
qua possibile sinistra né a sinistra con
noi perché ci sono le lettere sulle
porte come che cazzo vuoi tu non
seguirmi bay mila ai fastidio cosa devo
fare qua a per sondare giochi ma da
questo è stronzo a me vuoi puoi
mangiarti stop e il parrucchino giallo
che ciccio addosso così scemo libreria
quante porte ci sono in libreria la
madonna
[Musica]
ok ma cos'è a perfetto gaga si stronzo
mi taglia la testa solo a me cos'è lo
stronzo io qua dentro qua dentro in
mezzo non posso andare da altre parti se
non faccio così non so dove andare
ragazzi non ho idea
frate t'ammazzo sisley c tua sorella
stupida ragazzi che cosa succede
o quelle cazzate il tuo problema sfida
allora questo non è non è neanche con il
mezzo è allora spiega mi cosa devo fare
ci credo ciao ragazzi ma cosa sac mai
moby dick
ma spiega no no no no lo zio non si
osmetti a ritirarmi libris beh avete
cagato bene maledetti pinguini stupidi o
ci ho messo una vita per falsa dopo una
vita siamo scesi nelle segrete vi
rendete conto
bravo noi quella mia in questa la wii
smettere di seguirmi madonna mi sembri
signor bard con il pungiglione da vespa
di non so ora questa basta a seguirmi
che poi vai da un altro ragazzi io ci
provo e non so quanto possa funzionare
ma ci provo farmi tutti
la vendetta perché darti questo topo
nell'anno per tutto il video non è
servito a niente vero zio certo che
problemi ma spunta di bosco mettete no è
almeno quello sì siamo usciti da questa
torre quanto e crossa st torre di uscita
questa è l'uscita per cosa mi dice che
questa non è riuscita però io provo a
uscire
[Musica]
signori sono usciti davvero non ci
voglio credere tiro killed 44 volte sono
morto 44 volte si serio sono dei funghi
fuori va bene ragazzi io ho finito
veramente il gioco non ci posso credere
ciò non essere una vita alla taverna a
rimpinzarci di birra comunque sia
ragazzi a parte tutto è preso tutti gli
oppressi adesso toilette perché mi devi
far scegliere anche le toilette e dunque
alle donne racconta cosa è successo a
addio questo vi riguarda
va bene va bene sempre meglio che
tornare lì dentro va bene così quindi
ragazzi erano presenti ci sono tre
finali in poche parole basi in base alla
porta che scegli trovi un finale diverso
figata e io ho scelto quella delle donne
che mi ha portato rimosso la torre nudo
e mi ha fatto cadere quindi è il
peggiore di tutti ma tanto abbiamo
capito dall'inizio che io con le scelte
delle porte faccio abbastanza cagare
avere ragazzi concluso qui episodio di
lucky tower è stata fighissimo invece
tombotto c'era tipo tv i giochi tipo
escape quello con
con lo stick men per certi versi anche
più carino cioè non sa come va fra un
finissimo farei ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto concluso qui video cose che mi
è piaciuto sul momento non mi piace
anche vari social che comodi di cotone
descrizione ricordatevi se vedete
soppesato in giro le porte forti
maledizione anche la parte mia e noi
come al solito ci rivediamo nel prossimo
video della ragazza